It's so crazy. It's so crazy. It's so
insane. They see it as like being
friends with Destiny is such an honor.
You should just let him walk all over
you. He says jump. You ask how high. It
is so gross. He's such a low life. I've
never met this person in real life
before.
>> Lauren, I
>> I'm sorry. You're almost there. You're
almost at the point. That's actually a
good point.
>> It's so insane. The bomb's dropping.
It's crazy. So Connor was on my stream
last night and we spoke about my e
Israel thing from last week among other
stuff. And basically Destiny sat on his
stream sping the out about it the whole
time. And um guys if if you can believe
this this is the uh this is the
narrative now guys this is the kill shot
from one Mr. Banel is he con he pulls up
clips like the one where
says TDD on RFC live or whatever with
Connor and he says see they say TDD they
want me dead and that's that's the whole
narrative now guys I don't know if he I
I can only assume that he's being
dishonest and does know that TXD
is a very widely used phrase that We've
repurposed for pretty much every
different drama we've covered that
people online repurpose for pretty much
every drama they cover when they really
dislike someone. I can only assume he's
being dishonest and doesn't genuinely
think that there is a unique concerted
plan to his life up that is signified
with an acronym. However, at this point,
some kind of amphetamin psychosis is
actually becoming quite an explanatory
suggestion. Uh, so so I can't be sure
anymore. I can't be sure that he's lying
anymore. But that's basically how he
spent his stream last night was was
crying about that and acting as though
that means that I want to swat him or
have swatted him and so he can do
whatever he wants. So yeah, that's
that's the narrative right now, guys.
He's doing a good job ofing it up all by
himself. When you're you're dealing with
someone like someone like Destiny as
someone that does I I do genuinely hate
the guy. One of my biggest fears is that
they will eventually somehow have like a
uh come to Jesus moment, realize how
they'reing their own life up and um stop
and like you know throw their hands up,
show some humility and and start being
honest. That's honestly quite a big fear
sometimes. It's like, oh no, are they
going to are they going to realize how
bad that now I won't be able to talk
anymore? Then there won't be the same
person to hate there. But I think we're
safe. I think we're I I think with
Destiny, we're safe from that literally
ever happening. I do not think uh
Destiny will ever realize quite how bad
he'sing his own life up, which is just
great news for me, really. Which is just
great news to me. So he realizes he just
can't stop. Possibly true. Possibly
true. And that's got to be even more
crushing. So, where did Connor leave
JTalk? We want to see the end of the JTO
conversation because that gives us good
context,
>> I think. Go ahead and do it for you now.
Uh, lol. Esports Batman gave you dog
legal feedback on Pixie court case.
Therefore, he's complicit in all the bad
things that are happening in your
Discord server. Therefore, you deserve
to be docs. Get dip.
There. Was that uh was that sufficient
for the DJers in my chat?
>> Jesus. I
>> just between me and you Jtock that was
sarcastic. I was just I was just acting
out.
>> I know. I know. I know. I don't
>> what they wanted me to say. They they
wanted me to say that, you know,
>> like you understand that I actually of
everybody that I want to not be near
death. So basically JTO was saying to
Connor, um, yeah, this is all well and
good, but you and everyone around this
guy have been total [__] enablers for
the whole last few years. Uh, you know,
you've you you Connor have maybe stood
up once or twice and said something, but
Kyler's a total enabler. Dan's enabling.
Mutton's an enabler. You you're you're
letting this get worse. And Conor's
Conor's kind of like, yeah, I mean,
that's kind of true. Uh, but I'm tired.
I'm tied
>> like if if there's
>> they they wanted me to say that you know
>> like you understand that I actually of
everybody that I want to not be near
Destiny like if if there's like people I
don't want professionally associated
you're probably the one person I don't
want to be away from him because if
there's ever a chance that this guy's
going to redeem himself in some way
you're probably the only person who's
actually invested in it and everybody
else is just looking out for themselves
and money. So I actually don't want to
ruin your friendship. I actually don't
want you to be fighting with DGers who
are [__] They're like totally
mentally raped. It's fine. You should
just ignore them. They're not asking
>> the bridge. Don't fight with them.
>> Here's here's what I'm going to say.
Well, I'm mostly doing that for comedic
effect because they're so [__]
stupid. They don't even know what they
want. But uh what what I would say is
bridges and burn on my end. It's not
burn on my end. I would I was um I was
raised in the church for 18 [__]
years. I was raised to think that like
rapists,
murderers, and killers were capable of
redemption. So, Destiny being like kind
of sociopathic sometimes alone, which
kind of sucks and I find that sad, and
then lashing out when he feels like he's
being attacked, that's not the worst
thing I've ever seen people do. I've
seen a shitload of people do a lot
worse. As a matter of fact, that's part
of the reason why, you know, I think I
told you like two years ago, that's
that's why I continue to hang out with
Destiny because this is not the worst
[__] I've ever seen. I've had friends
who have done way [__] worse than
Stephen. Um, but my
>> presence 15 months
>> uh my presence comes with a condition
that I'm going to say what I think. So,
if you can't tolerate me saying what I'm
thinking, then [__] yourself, you know?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think um like
I I truly don't want you not to be
friends with this person. Even if maybe
you don't do content together, I don't
really care about that. It's um because
I I've already said that if if this guy
could just go and apologize and try to
make amends for the things he's done
wrong. Like I don't I don't personally
like I don't even like doing content on
him anymore to be honest with you. It's
just the lies about me, right? Like
unfortunately he's put me in a situation
where he's going to dox people in my
Discord. He's going to consistently
complain about me and make it seem like
despite apparently having knowledge of
other people who were willing to do far
more egregious actions, right? Having
explicit knowledge of these people, he's
going to blame the bad things that's
going on with him that are going on with
him on me, right? Going forward, putting
me at risk, doxing people around me,
right? I want I would much rather he
just try to make amends to those people,
apologize to them, try to make amends,
and we could all just go our separate
ways. That's what I would like. Well,
and funnily enough, uh that that was one
of the arguments. He was like, "Do you
think if
>> Oh, yeah. He's going to do that any day
now. I'm sure any day now, D is going to
throw his hands up and say, you know
what? I was wrong.
>> I stopped going after these people,
they'll stop going after me." And then,
weirdly enough, I feel like you just
said, you know, once we get past this,
let's stop going after each other.
>> I said like, "Make amends." Like, he
would have to do something to make
amends with these people. you would have
to actually feel some sort of um remorse
and try to make amends.
>> So these these [__] [__] Sorry,
I know you're saying I literally should
ignore them, but once again, like I
said, it's not burnt on my end.
>> What did Destiny do wrong? What did
Destiny do?
>> It's so funny. This is so funny, man.
This server is like everyone's personal
villain. It's everyone's personal
villain. There's not really a tease. I'm
just trying to subtly set people's
expectations that this is largely a 247
Dioro gayop server unless an Ethan Klein
mega attack server. As far as I'm aware,
it's mostly me. So, so is it is it the
server that's orchestrating the downfall
of Destiny's life? Is it a 247 Dioro
GayOps server? Or is it an anti-EN Klein
terrorist cell? Please, can we can we
decide on a narrative here? Can we Yeah,
very busy server. Very busy. very
militant, very efficient server. Okay.
>> Wrong. What did Dusty do wrong? Name
one.
>> The the reality. It's 3 weeks of
non-stop transbat. It's like a full
[__] month of trans Firebat from
[__] 6:00 a.m. to 11 at night. People
spamming [__] buzz gifts talking
about the trough and I rules. One thing.
Name one thing. Name one thing. Okay,
I'll name one thing. I can I considered
myself past tense friend with Destiny
and I would be his friend again. He got
consensual recordings of him engaging in
sex acts with women. He met a sex worker
who was posing as an 18 or 19year-old
sex worker, which was really a
26-year-old man that was getting photos
and videos of a 17 and 1/2year-old girl.
and he was catfished into sending
homemade pornography to said person
without the consent of the people with
whom the pornography was uh originally
produced and then it got leaked to the
[__] internet and everybody got
[__] pissed off. That's bad. I I I
don't know if you think that it's bad to
send homemade pornography to a random
person on the internet after talking for
to them for 2 weeks, but that's pretty
[__] bad. Same thing with uh why the
[__] are Lauren's DMs in there? Let's be
real. I don't think I've ever talked
about that. Why the [__] are Lauren's
DMs in there? Lauren Southern You know
what? Here's the real here's the real
real. Lauren Southern loved him. Lauren
Southern believed in him. Lauren
Southern saw that he was intelligent,
charismatic, funny, giving, gracious the
same way that I did. Steven could be a
great man. He actively chooses to be a
[__] So, I've tried to be his friend
for the past few years. So, hopefully he
stops being such a [__] over time, but
he's insisting on being a [__] So, my
doors open when he stops being a [__]
Okay,
there's two bad things. Stick it up your
[__] ass, you [__] losers.
>> I actually feel like that's a really
appropriate place to end the
conversation.
>> All right. Well, fair enough.
>> Thanks for talking to me.
>> Yeah, bro beans. Um, ride out the waves.
See you soon.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Have a good night. See you
later.
>> Bye. Wow. Listen, I'm tired and this
should have been a community night and
we should be playing video games right
now. And I should have bought a six-pack
so we could do this. And I don't have a
problem doing drama. I really don't. I I
I don't have a problem doing drama. But
you guys are some of the stupidest DG
[__] I've ever met in my entire
life. You th this once again, I don't
hate Stephen in general. He said some
rude [__] over the past 24 to 48 hours.
He says rude [__] all the time. That's
not my problem. My problem is that he
stopped telling his community how to
argue. And you guys are some of the
worst [__] arguers on the planet. You
are incapable of forming arguments
outside of something that's been
articulated by somebody else. You are
incapable of sourcing evidence. You are
incapable of following up. You are you
you're [__] incapable of thinking.
You are 80 IQ [__] [__] who
cannot [__] process complex
information. And if I let like if I was
uh you know a DGER from five [__]
years ago, I would be ashamed of y'all.
>> Okay, we got the idea,
>> right? So he leaves JTO
>> going 20 to 30.
>> He talks about stuff for a while
>> like I
>> eventually he joins this. This is uh the
melting pot guys. This is like the new
Darius Discord, I think, which is meant
to be like a replacement for what Jay
Stalks was for the years before. It's
where they all go to argue their drama
fight with all the other retards. So,
Connor joins in here and at some point
food shops is in here too. I think
around here food shops is in here and
then Wick joins and then eventually
Destiny comes in. But basically the DJs
as they always do. The moment someone
says, you know, I actually don't think
uh Destiny's right about this, they
desperately try and reprogram.
>> Do Do you know how many [__]
I've seen like backstabbed like
digitally raped and dead in a [__]
ditch over the past six years? Do you
know how many [__] I've seen
who were like decent content creators
>> and they couldn't handle what was
happening and the interpersonal drama
[__] and then they fell by the
wayside?
>> Arrist,
Demon Mama. Don't you take people Don't
you take people like when it comes to
that sort of thing like on a track
record though.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> Going to bring Rose Wrist up in that
because that's like a totally different
situation.
>> Who?
>> Rose Wrist. Not you, Connor. The other
person.
>> Yeah. Well, yeah, but like Rose Wrist
was a good content creator, made a
splash, had a decent amount of debates.
Everybody liked him. He had a small good
community. He could have been a
full-time creator if he wanted to be.
Then there was the white leafed internet
drama where they like the [__]
lefties took away his website and then
he said, "Fuck you. I'm going to go live
a normal life." And then he went and got
like an advanced degree in an advanced
job. Good for him, by the way.
>> But but for every wrist, there's another
dozen people that are also lost along
the wayside that I don't even remember.
>> Okay, so sorry to interrupt. Uh Kie is
going to move us into a special room
that's going to be completely locked to
everybody else. Uh, so guys, I'm already
noticing there are like there are two
reaction. There's like well, in fact,
it's just one reaction. There's just a
reaction to this whole drama that
immediately outs people as like the most
self-interested freaks in the world. The
people that are telling Connor, "This
shouldn't be done in public. This
shouldn't be done in public." They are
outing themselves as the most
self-interested freaks. And you you'll
see, I don't want to spoil stuff, but
you'll see as we go on. Oh, just just
letting you guys know. But yeah, caller,
if you're listening, please do it now.
But you guys can keep talking.
>> Wick mutton stardust.
>> What is I'm sorry. What is the streamer?
>> But
hi.
>> Hello.
>> Hey. Who's that?
>> Hey. What's up? What's up? Sorry.
>> My head was hurting from laughing last
night. This was peak content. This is
literally This is one of the most
amazing streams I've ever watched, man.
This is up there.
>> It's right there with with the Mr. Girl
breakup, you know? It's right up there
with you any any of these, man. It's
It's great. It was great
>> a room for whatever reason.
>> It's It's a locked room, so it's like
super secret. Yeah,
>> you might see it if you scroll down.
>> Why Why is
>> Well, all I'm trying to do is I'm just
trying to expand it so I can see it on
my screen.
>> Oh, there we go.
>> How did Chops get in here?
>> I I think this room has the same rules
as the uh streamer.
>> Is it called Supreme Stream?
>> Yeah. And apparently, I guess Callie
didn't set up the perms properly. Okay,
>> man. I'm afraid Destiny joins.
>> Okay, none of them are talking, so you
guys can like bring up like the material
issues.
>> Yeah, Parson, you were talking with
Connor. I'm going to try and call
Destiny or something.
>> No, he's he's he's out eating. I
wouldn't bother. It's cool.
>> Are you for real?
>> Oh my god.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I chatted earlier. Is just
bad timing. But yeah, I
>> invited me on the hippie dippy
>> dude.
You see the video? you pull up
Kilotonix's
uh Twitter. Why don't you share screen?
Why don't you scroll down it and why
don't we count how many tweets mention
other creators versus Destiny?
>> Let's do it. I'd love some evidence.
>> So, I guess they're trying to prove
Kilo's obsessed with Destiny.
>> That one Trump is we got related
you people certain that his channel will
die. All right. Are are you cool? Death
uncertainty. I am certain that is Wick
is asking you to check DMs. God. So, so,
okay, as we go through that, here's
something else that's going on as we go
through this. Okay, guys. Wick is like
in chat crying about everything. Wick is
nakedly like trying to use this to just
go after people he has existing grudges
with. And he's like projecting insanely
hard about what's going on. They are
saying, "We have spun Connor up into a
weapon and they're just using him to go
after other people." Connor has has
clearly got his own feelings about this
and is actually friends with Destiny and
has looked at the evidence, come to a
conclusion. Wick is literally just
latching on to little side things and
trying to use Destiny as like a
battering ram that goes in ahead. That's
lit. That is what's happening. That is
what's happening. And he's just like
trying, he's just projecting. And he's
just [__] projecting like crazy. So
Wick keeps coming in. He's like, "Conor,
Connor, you don't understand. Kilo said
that he's going to spread rumors about
me." And Quimman said that I touched
Ginger Ramoth's leg without consent. So
that's what Wick spent his time here
doing. And then he is pretending that
he's trying to help Destiny, that he's
trying. It's [__] crazy, guys. So, he
has sent Connor here his killshot
evidence. This is some of Wick's
killshot evidence, right? Um, like three
years ago, Kilo typed a message that
said, "I'm going to spread agitational
rumors about Wick TV/Death of Certainty.
I am certain that his career will die."
That's that's what that's what he said.
That's that's what that's what he typed,
guys. And so because he typed that guys,
Wick uses that to as a totally first of
all totally serious statement that is
said without even a a hint of irony or
or snark or tongue and cheek. Not even
nothing is a explicit statement of a
long plan of a of a clear plan that Kilo
has laid out where he's going to lie and
defame Wick. Now how is Wick lied and
defame? How is Akilo lied and defamed
Wick? Well, Wick can't identify a single
thing Kilo said about him that's
actually a lie. But he certain but it's
happening but because of that one
message. Okay. That means that the
progressive victory video is like fake
or something as well. Okay. Yeah.
Literally Ko Kilo's that message is an L
because this [__] does just use it.
But he literally can never point to a
lie. He can't point to a lie. He can't
point to a rumor. Even they even go like
even with me, right? They post this clip
of me talking about Ginger Ramoth saying
Wick did not have explicit consent to
touch her leg. I make no allegation in
that video. I don't say it's sexual
assault. All I do is say he didn't have
consent to touch her leg. I even make a
joke that clearly indicates that I think
it would be ridiculous to ask for
explicit consent to touch a leg. And I I
joke that anyone would be traumatized by
it. It's so clear he's actually just
upset about the fact that people are
mocking that it would that that any
rational woman Yeah. I was also just
saying what Ginger Ramoth said. That's
facts. Not the point though. Uh not the
point I'm making anyway. It's so obvious
that he's just upset about the fact that
I said it would be traumatic to most
women to have their leg touched by Wick.
He's just upset that I said something
mean and it got under his skin and so
he's going to keep banging on about it.
It's the same with the toothgate [__]
It's the same with the eating [__] It
gets under his skin and he gets a
[__] grudge about it. And he's a very
dishonest, stupid person. So he just
uses literally everything. He just uses
anything he can. So that's what he's
doing this whole time during this
stream. So this is him sending that Kilo
message.
>> [__] talk to any of you people.
[__] Wick is asking you to check DMs.
>> Same with Zardust. Yep. Kilo, I'm gonna
start spreading agitation rumors about
the streamer known as Wick TV, aka the
death uncertainty. I'm certain that his
channel will die. Yes, I know Kilo has
hated you for a long time. Cool.
All right. Are are you keeping a running
tally of uh how many tweets there are
versus how many of them are Destiny?
Whoever is scrolling on their Twitter.
>> Yeah,
>> you are keeping a running tally.
>> Mhm.
>> Well, what a deranged evil Twitter.
>> You guys are so gay.
>> Um
Jay Stock's calling me a gay ninja.
>> Yo, tell actually if you can let him if
you can let him know that uh the pod is
open to all if he has the link for it.
Discord.gg.
>> Bro, Radiant, shut up.
>> Well, no, I'm just I'm just saying cuz
he's apparently so scared that he
doesn't want to join even though
Connor's right here and he's ready to
talk to him. Uh Destiny 2 actually.
>> Uh but yeah, discord.gg/melted.
>> Hey, so uh going back to the food chops
thing, do you guys want to explain? You
think it's possible he cheaped out on
the tooth surgery paying for a lady of
the night that looks like ginger? It
would explain why he eats ramen so
weird.
>> I I think it's a a possibility worth
entertaining for sure. Thank you for the
£10. Thank you.
>> You guys don't like each other or was
the
>> Yeah, she jerks off to kids,
>> dude. Food chops just get just
mercilessly raped this entire [__]
stream as well.
>> It's gross.
shouldn't jerk off to kids.
>> Why defend a rapist? Why do that?
>> Who's a rapist?
>> J Stoke. Did you know that she's not a
>> child within within the same time? Okay.
Point to
>> Cherry. You're a [__] [__] Okay.
Number one, let's even pretend that.
>> Notice how you didn't deny that you jerk
off to kids. So, why don't we just go
ahead and answer this question right
now. Do you jerk off to kids?
>> No.
>> Okay. Do you jerk off to cartoon
drawings of kids?
>> Yeah,
>> there you go.
>> But but notice but notice how but notice
how you go after me for
>> cartoon depictions.
>> Stop jerking off the cartoon kids.
>> I I I let you finish. I'll let you
finish.
>> I don't care if you let me finish. Stop
jerking off the cartoon kids. It's
[__] gross.
>> Okay, then stop depending rapists. Stop
>> jerking off the cartoon kids. It's
[__] gross. That's such a Wait, you
guys are bringing up like the most
difficult
>> You really You really got me. You really
got me.
>> I did. You jerk off to cartoon kids.
It's [__] gross. Stop doing it.
>> I mean, she just seems like you're
scared of what I want to say. I don't
even know what
>> I'm just going to repeat this for the
next 30 minutes whenever food shop
stops. You jerk off two cartoon
children. Stop masturbating to cartoon
children. Are you going to agree to stop
masturbating to cartoon children? Boot
chops. Connor, is there going to be an
actual conversation? Like about
I'm gonna ask you a very simple
question, which is, are you going to
commit to no longer masturbating to
cartoon children?
>> Just say yes. We can move on.
>> Why the [__] Yeah, I'm totally going to
stop. Okay.
>> Okay. That sounds like sarcasm. So, I
don't [__] believe you. And they just
said just say yes. So, I don't [__]
believe you.
>> No, no, no. He's right. Instead of
masturbating to cartoon kids, um, I'll
just think of you instead of
>> Don't do it. You'll just do what?
>> I just think of you instead
>> is Wait, someone said Wick is here. Oh,
Wick.
>> I'm here.
>> Okay, so can we move on from the free
conversation? It sounds like it's like
stuck at a dead end. Like, do you have
any He doesn't He's too cowardly. He's
too cowardly to actually have a
conversation or a debate. It's fine.
>> Sorry. What What do you want to talk
about besides the fact that you jerk off
to cartoon kids?
>> No, I'm just saying you're a total
hypocrite. So,
>> in what way? you do this moral frogging
even though like you literally run cover
for people who um defend Pixie's like
harassment of other women and um you I
don't see you mentioning Jes like rape
of Cherry so I don't know why
>> yeah yeah so yeah go go ahead and
explain that one how did JT rape Cherry
>> uh Cherry was uh institutionalized right
I like Uh, maybe I should pull this up.
Cherry tweeted about this basically
being like, "Jay didn't rape me." I
mean, not that you guys need this
explained to you, but obviously the only
reason they do this is because Destiny
is a disgusting
uh psycho, like some sort of [__] gay
demon who is desperate to hurt women at
any cost. Uh, so he just constantly
brings up Cherry and accuses talks about
Cherry being crazy because he wants to
twist the knife and and hurt her and
hurt JTO by extension. Um, so JTO tries
not to address any of this stuff as far
as I know. Cherry says here, "My ex Jtok
did not rape me. I have forwarded the
concerns of recent harassment to the
police handling my case and will now
continue to keep to myself, focus on
everything good in my life." So
>> how the [__] is she able to consent?
Like wouldn't she be
>> sex before or afterwards?
>> Uh, does it even [__] matter? Hello.
>> Yeah. Do do you think do you think if
somebody is temporarily mentally
incapacitated they're permanently
mentally incapacitated?
>> Do you Okay. Okay. Do you think that
>> you can answer that question? Do you
think if somebody's temporarily mentally
incapacitated they're permanently
mentally incapacitated?
>> Can I
>> No. No. Now let me explain.
>> Obviously not.
>> So if if Okay. Soing this specifically
>> because
she wants to [__] say that Jtock is a
[__] rapist which makes her jerking
off to cartoon kids. Okay. Can I just
say if this is going to just be like uh
Connor's beef with food shops, I have no
interest. But I do want to talk.
>> Destiny. Destiny's coming in like I
think 10 minutes from now cuz he's like
that was the whole reason why I was
organizing. We're just kind of like
killing time until he gets here.
>> I understand. But I I want
>> Connor is so [__] dude. He is the
one comparing Lolly to actual rape is so
crazy. That's so insane. But yeah,
>> it's so crazy. It's so crazy. It's so
insane.
off the kids, you [__] freak. I don't
even know why they tolerate just loop on
this over and over and over again.
incarcerated
something about
>> I think I wanted to just if I may if I
may like counter points
>> I I l I got banned from Connor's chat or
timed out from Connor's chat for for
putting the little chi Chinese man emoji
and then retyping what food shops were
saying like it's so crazy you clash
Connor you clashing out you clashing out
Connor
>> um Connor
>> what
>> buddy
I understand that you feel
>> he's afraid. He's 100% afraid.
>> No, I felt this way for a year.
>> I know. I get it.
>> I felt this way the entire time. I think
you're [__] disgusting. And the fact
that you don't you haven't changed your
mind. And whenever somebody brings up
the fact that you [__] jerk off to
Cartoon Kids, you just go, "Oh, I said
that a long time." You think people
don't notice? You think people don't
notice that you don't rebut the fact
that you still engage with Lollcon, but
you [__] said, "Oh, I said this a
long time." You think people don't
[__] notice that you're a [__]
pedo?
>> No, I know. It's okay. I'll think of you
instead. I'll think of you instead. I'll
think of you instead. Okay, it's okay.
>> That would Well, I'm an adult man, so
that would be a step in the right
direction.
>> Hell yeah. See, that's what I'm talking
about. See? Done. Topic done, right? You
won't bring this up again in the future.
Okay, you should. No, I will bring every
time I say something [__] I'm going
to bring this
>> but I'll jerk off. I'll I'll jerk off to
you instead. Okay, it's okay.
>> That is a upgrade.
>> Hell yeah. See, that's what I'm talking
about. That's an agreeing right there.
>> Yes, you jerk off to a
>> take one for the team.
>> Wait, let's let's let's let Wick speak.
Let's let Wick speak. Quick, speak your
mind.
>> I get it, Connor. I do. I think
yesterday went yesterday didn't have
>> Dude, it literally it like gives me such
echoes the Mr. Girl [__] man. when you
get these [__] creeps like Wick
coming in like Connie, you know, you
don't you don't have to do this, Connor.
You don't have to do this
>> to go how it did. There was a path and I
think that there was a way so everyone
to win. But
and I get why. I think that you you let
kind of your stubbornness uh your your
just
>> I love how I say to Connor, "Oh yeah, I
really hate Hutch and Wick." I think
there's lots of reasons to hate Hutch
and Wick other than their association
with Destiny and then Wick just like
show ch show ch show ch show ch show ch
show ch shows his colors so obviously
here like just wanted to prove me right
>> your feeling of being attacked and under
pressure kind of get you to make
decisions that I think that you you
didn't have to make I
>> yeah he was crashing out
>> well hold on I I want to be fair to
counterpoints because I I do sympathize
right like and I I raid and I wasn't
here to thank Thank you for the raid if
you raided.
>> Everything happened like the first time
I hopped on and and I I I thought it
went well. Like, hey, I get it. You
don't want to compromise your
principles. Um, fair enough. Uh, but
look, there is a mass amounts of people
attacking someone that you consider a
friend, coming at them like way beyond
just like uh um making fun of him or
critical of his takes and things like
literally trying to ruin his life. So,
he asked you a favor, right? He asked
you a favor like, "Hey, I don't want
these people in communities connected to
me." Now, I get it. You don't want to
ban anyone for that. And you know what?
I was able to talk to him the day before
and get a compromise as well. Like, hey,
I don't want to ban people that uh just
for for saying things, right? Like, I
don't want to ban that, but I was a and
he was very reasonable with me. Like, so
I don't I don't know why you guys didn't
go that route. Like why not? What
happened?
>> Because I'm not going to accept the
implicit threat of what's being said.
>> It's it's not an implicit threat.
Someone for a favor.
>> You know, [__] that. You know full
goddamn well as much as I [__] do.
Mutin so much has confirmed it that the
simple ask of don't allow snarkers in
your community in order to endlessly
[__] [__] talk me. That never
happened in my [__] community.
There's no [__] evidence that it ever
[__] happened in my community.
They're making this [__] up [__]
whole cloth. And so the implication is
kick these two people from your [__]
community or else we don't hang out
anymore. I've been [__] hanging out
with Steven for six goddamn years. I
deserve more than that. And if he
doesn't [__] like it, then he can
[__] off.
is like all people who either have never
had a real friendship or they they see
it as like being friends with Destiny is
such an honor that you should you should
have no spine. You should just let him
walk all over you. Whatever he asks he
he says jump you ask how high because it
is just such a gift to be in his
presence. It's like it's only one of
these two.
>> Sorry. What was funny pedophile?
>> What
>> dude?
Ignore food chopped. Ignore food
chopped. What was what was funny? The
person who jerks off the cartoon kids
who shouldn't have a career at all.
You're going to get you're going to
start losing on this. Look, again, there
were paths where you didn't have to kick
anyone out. I understand that it was um
that you feel that it was a and I I
don't hang out in the cog, so I can't
speak either way to whether it's true or
not, right? It doesn't matter. Um but
there like even giving him the chance to
kind of come in, check every once in a
while, see what's going on. He's not the
police.
>> He's not. But he's your friend, bro.
>> Yeah. And my [__] friend should have
the [__] balls to allow people to
talk [__] about him on the [__]
internet. Or if he's going to say,
"These people are engaged in a life
ruination campaign against me." Then
they should be able to produce evidence.
And if they don't produce evidence, I'm
going to tell them, I'm telling you, you
think yesterday was bad. I'm tired now.
I just talked to the [__] snarkers
for six hours. It's going to be bad
tonight. It was because I'm not going to
[__] have this [__] where it's
go, "Oh, these two people are bad.
Remove them from your community." Okay.
Can you produce evidence that these two
people are bad? Nope. You just have to
trust me.
>> Here he is. So, Destiny joins here.
Destiny joins here.
>> You did produce evidence. You may not
have found it sufficient, but that
evidence exists. I can confirm some of
it exists.
>> So, so do we do
>> or not?
>> Do we doxed you? Again, these people are
all connected. It's like structure like
an ISIS.
>> It's like ISIS. Wick says guys, it's
like ISIS.
>> Wick with the school counselor about to
break the law vibes. It's a secret.
>> Thank you for the $5. Huge appreciated.
Thank you. It's so crazy, man. The
delusion these guys have spun themselves
up into because they get a few mean
tweets is [__] hilarious, man. It's
like ISIS, bro. Get a grip. Get a
[__] grip.
>> You did produce evidence.
>> You may not have found it sufficient,
but that evidence exists. I can confirm
something.
>> Some of it exists.
>> So, so doxed or not?
>> Doxed you.
>> Again, these people are all connected.
It's like
in ISIS the uh the people in that don't
do the bombing but they are the reason
why I'm ask oh so you you have you have
like a videotaped sermon of death of
Dubbie
>> being an ISIS proitizer
>> you go ahead and please give me that
>> he's like a propagandist dude
>> yeah you just said that he's the
propagandist so do you have do you have
the video or extended text messages of
the propagandist.
You mean you having you mean you having
Dubie on the entire time? Like we don't
even need to look at like Dubie in the
voice chat. Like why do we even need to
look at that? You're the one who had him
on.
>> What did Dubie say that you think is
incorrect?
>> The way that he kind of moral about
Steven mind raping literally every
single woman that comes his way. What
are you talking about? Like he's using
your platform to do it.
>> I'm sorry. Does Steven not [__] mentally
ill women routinely? When do Wait, who
what is our example? Hold on. Let's
Let's run this out real quick, okay?
Because these memes are going on for way
too long. What is our strongest example
of this?
>> Strongest example.
>> Yeah.
>> How about Brit?
>> So, dude, this was a bomb. This is like
Brit. Brit. Like, now it could be a few
Brits. Could be a few Brits, but it's
it's not it's none of the ones that
you're thinking of. It's a whole new
Brit.
>> Strongest example.
>> Yeah.
>> How about Brit? I've never met this
person in real life in my entire life.
>> Yeah. Are you communicating with them?
>> And then the immediate, you know, you
know, immediately
this guy is [__] terrified of
whatever this is. This guy does not want
to handle it. I've never met this person
in real life. Okay. So, this is someone
you're talking to. This is someone
you're sexing with.
>> Strongest example.
>> Yeah.
>> How about Brit?
>> I've never met this person in real life
in my entire life. It's like immediately
this is like Mr. Girl all over again,
man. This is him joining. You're still
sexing Anna. The This is It's the It's
all over again, man. I was like, you
know, [__] it. I was ratatouille critic
taken back taking back to his childhood
taking a bite into this into this
content. Okay. I was like, bro, what is
happening? What's happening?
>> I've never met this person in real life
in my entire life.
>> Yeah. Are you communicating with them
right now? They try to add me on 50
million different accounts, but right
now, no, I am not.
>> Yeah, I know you are.
>> Okay. I'm literally not. I bet if I
check messages right now, I bet that
they probably have a thing saying,
"Please add me again." But you said you
said I [__] mentally ill women. Who What
is the strongest go-to example of [__]
mentally ill women?
>> Sherry Anavoir.
>> Okay, let's start with Sherry. Molina,
let's hold on.
>> Hold on.
>> Lauren Southern. No, no, no. Okay, hold
on. Wait. Are all those people in the
same category of mental illness to you?
>> And look at the shift, man. We go from
who's your strongest example to what
other ones are there to are those really
all in the same category? You are just
raped. You [__] lost. You [__]
lost, dude. Holy [__] No. Lauren
Southern is substantially more stable
than the rest of the women.
>> Do you think Molina was mentally ill?
>> I think Molina is substantially more
stable than the rest of them. Okay,
let's say that Cherry um is mentally
ill. I think I would probably
>> This sick [__] loser is just
desperate to latch on to the Cherry one
because he literally just wants to twist
the knife because he is a sick [__]
pervert. It is so gross. He's such a low
life.
>> Agree with that. I think as a result of
her being mental, I think I curved her
for like two plus years. Um, she seemed
to be fine with rolling through whatever
and wanted to make content or whatever.
It was a thing I was aware of. We talked
about it. I think she meed me like two
times before. It was just what it was.
Let's assume that I shouldn't have seen
her the third time. Okay. By the way,
the second time you me cuz I didn't want
to hang out with her, but that's fine.
Let's assume that I um
>> So before this third time that they're
talking about, which assumably is like
this time where he recorded um before
this third time, he she'd already me too
him twice.
>> Let's assume that I shouldn't have seen
her the third time. You acknowledge that
Jistle's behavior is at least like three
orders of magnitude
have done with Jerry.
>> Why? Because he institutionalized her.
>> Because he institutionalized her for 3
days and then
>> what if she was threatening suicide?
Let's go ahead and slow down and explore
that. What if she said, "Fuck you,
Jtock. I'm going to commit suicide." Do
you think he should have
institutionalized her?
>> Yeah.
>> So what So what the [__] is the
complaint?
>> Okay. Do you think that bringing her on
his stream for 6 months afterwards to do
content for him?
>> Direct thing that was causing her to go
crazy was an unbelievably insane thing
to do.
>> Why Why are we even talking about JTO?
My contention is
>> 70% of your [__] problems are because
you [__] crazy women.
>> Yeah, I I literally I don't think that
timeline's true. I could I could be
wrong. I don't think that's time's true.
Your [__] problems are because you
[__] crazy women.
>> I'm going to re ask the same question.
You just tried to run from that so hard.
>> I'm not running from [__] J Even if
JTO's worse than you. Let's say Jtock's
a [__] rapist. What does that have to
do with you?
>> If if that's what you
>> JTO's a rapist.
>> Okay. What does that do about you?
>> No, no, no. That's fine. As long as you
acknowledge Jay-Z's a rapist, that's
fine. Okay. Um, who's an ex? So, beyond.
>> So, like it's crazy. He's [__]
flailing, dude. It is just he is just
desperately trying to do this [__]
Davo [__] and just flailing the [__]
out. He is like a cornered [__] rat,
bro. So [__] desperate.
>> Who is an adult, by the way, and is
married, by the way, and can also make
decisions, by the way.
>> The frame is just totally broken. Mask
is totally gone. Literally can't hold it
together anymore. Cannot hold together
his [__] [__] narcissist image.
>> These things, right?
>> Yeah. That's why I'm not a snarker. It's
because I think they have agency, too.
>> Okay. Do you think there's like a moral
wrong in the two of us having sex
consensually with one another?
>> I think if you No, my stream isn't
turned off. Why'd you say that? Your
donor didn't come through. Connor got
divorced because he decided to make
Nurgal law videos for six years straight
and in one night gave a masterclass
performance unlike anything I've ever
seen in a streamer I've given thousands
of dollars to who can't mute mute his
mic when he talks. Thank you for the
$420, Jimly. Huge appreciate.
>> Thank you.
>> Know that it's going to [__] implode
at some point. You should [__] learn
your lesson.
>> That's nice dodge, [__] Let me ask
you again. Do you think it's a moral
wrong for me and Cherry to hook up with
each other?
>> Yes.
>> Why?
>> All women
because you already know through your
sexual history that what's going to
happen is you're going to be too aloof.
You're going to be too gone. And if
these women have [__] un un
underlying [__] mental issues, you're
gonna trigger the [__] out of them and
then you're gonna have to fight them off
of you.
>> Okay. So, is it immoral for anybody to
hook up with Cherry or just streamers or
just me?
>> Do you Let's just go to Brit. It's the
easiest one.
>> Talk about Cherry. I want to talk about
Cherry right now.
>> Okay. Are you talking about Cherry the C
H A E I R Y? The half black chick.
>> Who have we been talking about?
>> I don't [__] know. There's Trans
Cherry. Maybe you had sex with Trans
Cherry, too. I don't know.
>> Who have you been talking about the
whole time?
>> I probably been talking about Cherry.
>> That's who I've been talking about. Yes.
>> Okay. You just pronounced it weird.
>> Okay. What about it?
>> Call her Cherry. So, I'm just curious.
Is it immoral or unethical for Cherry to
hook up with anybody or
>> somebody who should somebody who's ready
to deal with her [__] insanity?
>> I I don't know what kind of answer that
is. Is it immoral for Cherry to hook up
with who who would be an example of
somebody ready to hook up with her or
and deal with her in saying what does
that even mean?
>> Okay, hold on. So So let let me go ahead
and ask the exact same question back to
you. There's a woman who's married.
>> She claims she's in an open
relationship.
>> She just had a miscarriage and she's
obsessed with you.
>> So this is about Cherry, right? So he
was saying that only the third time they
hooked up was a mistake, right? and that
he he couldn't have known anyway. That's
that's basically what he's trying to
say. It's so [__] But
>> should you have sex with her?
>> Probably not. But by the time she said
he did, though, right?
>> Not after she said she was obsessed with
me. No.
>> So now he's claiming that she said she
was obsessed with him after um that
third hookup. And there's no way he
could have possibly known that she had
any fixation or issues there beforehand.
It's just so [__] absurd. It is so
[__] absurd what he's trying to spin
here, man.
>> Oh,
>> okay.
>> That was the thing she said after she
left. But let's assume. No, we don't.
Actually, I'm not going to assume. Why
the [__] does any of this matter?
>> It matters because if you No, no, I can
articulate this to you perfectly.
>> Okay.
>> If you wake up and you meet a [__]
[__] that's a [__] you know,
whatever. That's like,
>> can we not do the two?
>> That's a bad day. You Everyone's a
[__] [__] You're the [__]
You're the [__]
>> Connor. If I've Let's assume for a sake
of argument I've hooked up with 200 plus
women and it's the same two that people
like you who obsess over my sex life for
whatever reason always bring up like
why? Like nothing between me and Cherry
was like he raped this person or the his
treatment.
>> Okay. When did you meet Brit? You want
to play this game? Let's play this game.
When did you meet Brit?
>> I've never met this person in real life
before.
>> Okay. When did you meet her digitally?
>> It's so crazy, man. He tries it again.
I've never met this person in real life
before.
>> I don't remember. I'm not going to dig
through here and have you audit the
[__] lives of people who [__] DM
me crazy [__] on Discord, though. This
is not relevant to the conversation. And
this is a new person. It is relevant to
the conversation, isn't it?
>> This is a new person that you want to
attack me with, Connor. But it has
nothing to do with the reason why you've
obsessed psychosexually over my sex life
for the past like three [__] years.
When your friend is trying to give you
advice on how you're [__] your life
up, you're psych psychosexually obsessed
with me, dude. It just show It just
shows he literally he cannot even from
his friends take even the slightest
criticism. If he's given advice about
how he's [__] his life up completely,
it is like immediately he's immediately
into ego protection mode. It is
immediately like, "No, that couldn't
possibly be true. Everything I do is
perfect." It's so [__] insane, man.
He is such a [__] psycho.
>> At least,
>> do you know why?
>> You are reaping what you've seown. You
are reaping what you've seown and you
haven't learned your lesson and it
sucks.
>> Okay. In my current court case drama,
who what is the what what is the seown
part? What did I sew here? Was it Pixie?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, why was it immoral for me to
have sex with Pixie? Or was it immoral?
>> It wasn't immoral for you to have sex
with Pixie. It was immoral for you to
take her [__] homemade pornography
and send it to somebody that you'd only
known for 10 days.
>> Okay. So, it was obvious for us. So, it
was immoral for us to record something
or it was immoral for us to trade it or
what?
>> It's immoral for you to trust somebody
you've never met after 10 days with
homemade pornography
of your
>> I feel like Connor is still giving him
some grace here by not locking in on the
non-consensual part. I feel like he's
trying to avoid [__] in his court
case, which kind of loser behavior, but
hey,
>> let's assume that's the case. Then
>> let's assume that that's true to anybody
with a [__] brain,
>> Connor. Then why did Pixie okay to share
with a woman she's never even met in her
life?
>> So this is because Pixie agreed that he
could share it with his wife, with
Molina. Okay, Pixie agreed that you
could he could share it with Molina. So,
why the [__] wouldn't she be okay with
me sending it to Rose, the 26-y old man
posing as a 17 17year-old girl posing as
a uh 18year-old girl selling nudes on
Twitter without asking because he would
share it with with his wife. So, it's
like the same thing because they haven't
met. Destiny, when I'm I'm not talking
about everybody else. I'm talking about
you. talking about me and Molina.
>> I'm talking about you,
>> Connor. If me and Okay, hold on. Do you
think that Pixie deserved it then? Did
she reap what she sewed?
>> Yes. She's a dumb [__] She shouldn't
have [__] shot homemade pornography
with you.
>> Does every single person who shoots
homemade pornography and have it leaked?
Are they all reaping what they've seown?
>> Destiny, how about this question?
>> Do you think it's smart to send homemade
pornography to somebody you've only
known for 10 days?
>> I don't know. Ask anybody else.
>> What do you mean you don't know?
What do you mean you don't know? You're
a you're a multi-millionaire
niche celebrity and you don't know
whether it's a wise move to send your
homemade pornography to random people
online. What the [__] are you saying?
What the [__] are you saying?
>> Oh, no. No, no. Answer that question. Do
you THINK IT'S PRUDENT? DO YOU THINK
IT'S PRUDENT to send homemade
pornography to somebody when you've only
known them for 10 days? Yes or no?
>> Sure, Conor. That was the behavior that
everybody
>> Wait, you're saying yes, it is prudent?
>> Conor, why does this matter?
>> This has Yeah, you
>> Why does this matter? BECAUSE THIS
[__] HAS TORCHED endless
professional opportunities for his
[__]
That's why that's [__] matters
recommendations from you. You [__]
[__] I think I'm doing okay
professional. He is literally in it's
fullblown just defending his ego. All he
can do is just try and save his ego.
>> I don't need recommendations from you
for how to run my life. Number one.
Number two.
>> Yes, you do. You dumb [__] Because you
keep burning your own life.
>> Number two, I'm not the one.
>> YOU NEED A [__] social worker.
>> Holy [__] You're so ass pain over your
sexual obsession with my life.
>> No, I'm not. YOU [__] OKAY, FINE.
[__] THIS. SHUT UP. Shut up. I'll just
say it. I'll just say it. After you
leaked homemade pornography, after the
entire internet hated you,
>> you started sexing with another woman on
Discord,
>> and you [__] did age play with this
[__] and she WAS MARRIED TO SOMEONE
ELSE, AND SHE WAS MARRIED TO A GROPER.
YO, she
>> It's insane. It's insane, dude.
It's [__] crazy. Total nuke. Total
[__] nuke,
guys. No, you don't understand. He's on
Viveance now. The risky sexual behavior
has stopped. He's not going to do
There's never going to be anything
[__] like that again. You are age
playing with a grip's wife. You are age
playing with a groper's wife. You are
age playing with a graper's wife. And
she's threatening to kill herself. And
you're age playing with her. [__]
insane. It's so [__] insane. Run it
back.
>> From you for how to run my life. Number
one. Number two.
>> Yes, you do. You dumb [__] Because you
keep burning your own life.
>> Number two. I'M NOT THE ONE.
>> YOU NEED A [__] social worker.
>> Holy [__] You're so ass pain over your
sexual obsession with my life.
>> No, I'm not. You [__] OKAY, FINE.
[__] THIS. SHUT UP. Shut up. I'll just
say it. I'll just say it. After you
leaked homemade pornography, after the
entire internet hated you, you started
sexing with another woman on Discord and
you [__] did age play with this [__]
and she WAS MARRIED TO SOMEONE ELSE
>> AND SHE WAS MARRIED to a groper.
>> She was married to a groper.
>> SHE WAS married to a groper. Do you
think it is sexually prudent TO SEXUALLY
TEXT message somebody who's married to a
groper?
>> Conor, aren't you?
>> Do I need to pass through every single
person that messages me with a [__]
nude or wants to Is that what I need to
do? Do I need to get permission from you
from now on? Are you going to tell me
how to run my [__] personal life?
>> But if anybody was your [__] friend,
they would call you an idiot to your
face, which is what I'm doing right now.
You are an idiot.
>> You are dumb. Wait, wait, wait. No,
wait.
>> You ruin your own life.
>> Okay. All right. Does any of this I
don't know what the point if the point
here is for Connor to go I don't like
the way that you have sex with people or
whatever. I don't know what the [__] the
point is of this conversation. That's
it.
>> I'm sorry. Okay. Yeah, fine. I'll ask
you this question. I I'll make the point
in abundantly clear. When you're being
sued for leaking homemade pornography,
should you start sexually text messaging
a woman who's married to a political
opposition that hates your [__] guts,
>> dude. Conor, at this point,
>> is that sane or normal behavior?
>> Everyone hates me. You don't understand.
Everyone hates me. The world hates my
[__] guts.
>> Oh my god.
>> What I do with my
>> Wait. Okay, so the whole world hates
your guts. HOW DO YOU KNOW IT'S DOOBIE
SWATTING?
>> WHAT I DO, CONNOR? What I do? I've never
said that. Doobie himself has swatted
me. Like, he's too stupid.
>> So, how do you know it's J? How do you
know it's the Snarkers?
>> Because these guys literally have the
[__] slogan at the beginning of their
[__]
>> But the husband,
>> dude, literally, he's trying to sneak in
this [__] TDD [__] as well, man.
He's just flailing. He's totally lost
it. This guy is [__] disconnected
from reality entirely. He's totally lost
his [__] mind. Literally, anything
but admit that he's [__] up. Anything
but admit that These are the
consequences of his own actions.
>> Everyone go out and buy $400 worth of
40k figurines right now.
>> Thank you for the $5, Jimly. Hugely
appreciated. Thank you so much, dude. It
just no dignity left. Nothing. He is
literally just a trembling [__]
fearful animal. It's crazy, dude.
>> How do you know it's Doobie swatting
you?
>> What I do, Connor? What I do? I've never
said that Doobie himself has swatted me.
like he's too.
>> So, how do you know it's J? How do you
know it's the Snarkers? Because these
guys literally have the [__] slogan
at the beginning of their [__]
>> But the husband
>> But the husband was in a telegram
channel where gropers were plotting your
murder. If they were plotting your
murder, then don't you think they might
swat you?
>> I don't know. They might, but I've
gotten swatted.
>> You're so full of [__]
You are so full of [__] Listen to me.
You are so full of [__] You want you
want to blame exclusively
Queen J all of these people for why your
life is [__] up. And yet you always
poke the bear. You always [__] crazy
[__] You It's everybody else's
fault.
>> EVERYBODY ELSE'S FAULT. It's never
Destiny's fault. It's never Steven's
fault. We can't do a moral inventory
about what the [__] you're doing every
single goddamn day.
>> Conor is he got I No. No. Yes. Yes, it I
want to I want you to just say that
because I sex people or [__] a lot of
people. It is absolutely everything
that's happened is my fault because of
that.
>> Yeah. When you try to [__] a married
woman of your political opposition that
wants to murder you and then you try to
blame people who hate you on the
internet for trying to swat you, but
then there's other people who want to
murder you, too. I'm going to say you're
full of [__] Yeah, absolutely.
>> That's
>> okay. So, your your contention is that
this group of people, I guess, are
they're the ones swatting me. I didn't
get
>> I have more evidence that they're
swatting them swatting you than you have
presented that the snarkers are swatting
you.
>> Connor, you have no evidence they've
swatted me.
>> Yeah, you're right. And yet I still have
more than you.
>> And yet I still have more than you.
>> Testimony evidence.
>> What's the evidence that I have? I have
the evidence.
>> Wait going. Would you consider my
testimony evidence? Would you Would you
consider my testimony evidence? You
know, they're really mean to me. You're
queen that said I sexually assaulted
Ginger Ramoth. didn't by the way a
telegram channel plotting Steven's
murder but you want to take all the
negativity that's on the internet about
you and you want to assign it to one
community
>> these full of [__]
>> you're full of [__]
>> this telegram group appeared like a year
after my first swatting incident I don't
know why you're pretending that
everything came from that is this is
this the new JL talking point
>> I'm not
>> Is this the new J talking point by the
way. Connor got these screenshots.
Connor got all this Brit stuff, these
screenshots of his Telegram group
plotting his murder. That all came from
the this Brit and her husband. That's
where he was getting this from. Nothing
to do with JTO. Literally nothing to do
with this side of things whatsoever.
These are literally he is getting
dragged into the insane messy [__] that
Destiny's getting into. Totally
independent of anyone else. You are
being obtuse. I'm saying there's enough
[__] who hate you on the
internet for good reason that to say
that this is just the snarkers is the
most hilarious gay [__] cope I've
ever heard in my entire life. By the
way, do you want to go ahead and
reassert your evidence for how the cog
do you want to reassert your evidence
for how the cog is compromised because
we have two [__] [__] snarkers in
our discord?
>> Disavow the cog is compromised because
you run it, [__] The simple the
>> You're such a You're so full of [__]
>> Conor. Conor,
>> it's mindblowing.
>> Conor, I have never in my
>> I have never in my life said that every
swatting attempt or whatever has come
from the uh H3 whatever the [__] the
snarker people. I don't actually 100%
know that the very
>> dude and he just starts admitting but
it's all just [__] [__] man. He
just starts admitting that it's all
[__] Connor just breaks this guy
and the whole narrative is just
crumbling. First time I got swatted was
after the
>> So why do they deserve the doxing? I
thought I I thought esports Batman,
Wicked Supreme, Jtock, uh Jtock, Queman,
Doobie, I thought they all deserve
doxing because they were complicit in
your doxing, swatting, and harassment. I
thought that's why they deserve to be
doxed.
>> No, it's because they haven't
>> No. So, well, is it no% know that? The
very first time I got swatted was after
the
>> So, why do they deserve the doxing? I
thought I I thought esports Batman,
Wicked Supreme, Jtock, uh Jtock, Queman,
Doobie, I thought they all deserve
doxing because they were complicit in
your doxing, swatting, and harassment. I
thought that's why they deserve to be
doxed.
>> No, it's dude. Oh my god, he's broken.
He's lost it. He just admits it's all
bunk. It's all raped. It's all just
nonsense conspiracy skits [__] to try
and smear people because he's sick of
them talking. Oh my god, it's so good.
did so perfect.
>> I thought I I thought esports Batman,
Wicked Supreme, Jtock, uh Jtock, Queman,
Doobie, I thought they all deserve
doxing because they were complicit in
your doxing, swatting, and harassment. I
thought that's why they deserve to be
doxed.
>> No, it's because they have engaged in a
year and a half post [__] We could
just watch your content for the last 6
months and see you running away from
your own talking points. How are how are
you running away from your own talking
points right now?
>> These aren't my talking points. These
are the talking points that have
>> Okay, so why did esports Batman deserve
to get doxed?
>> No, I'm going to answer the other
question that you asked me before you
try to railroad to some other question.
You said, "What is my issue with these
people?" and I've said it and I've
clarified it 50 billion [__] times is
that for a year and a half these people
have run a real life long-term
harassment campaign that has
encapsulated multiple channels, multiple
Discords and multiple mediums like
websites like Kiwi Farms and Discord and
other people's stream chats and other
people's [__] donations and
everything else that that has been
dedicated to the total destruction of my
career and my life. That's been my
issue. Yeah. And they're stochastically
responsible. How how do they do that?
Well, they they make YouTube videos
talking about their opinions and all the
bad [__] I do. And then sometimes they
talk in Discord about their thoughts on
on the bad [__] I do and that's why they
have to die. Well, for your swatting and
doxing. Yeah,
>> Connor, I'm not a baby. I don't give a
[__] if some cops show up to my house
with some guns. What I care about is if
people are getting harassed who are
peripheral to me in my life where people
are making threats to them where these
people are not the worst
cry about [__] doxing. Swatting is
annoying. I do admit it. And I do
consider a kind of attempted murder, but
I could deal with that. What I can't
deal with is every single person
peripheral in my life getting
mindfucked. Like I'm watching you.
You're mind raped right now. That stuff
is a lot worse to me because I have no
control over that. I can't do anything
to influence that
rifles again.
>> Do you think JTO convinced me that you
engage with like insane sexual behaviors
that puts you at incredible risk? your
obsession with
>> in a few months or so when a notable
YouTuber makes a video essay on Destiny
that know is going to be generational.
>> Thank you for the $5. Huge appreciated.
That's not the only thing that's said in
here that will be generational. Okay.
Well, we're not even there yet, but
that's crazy [__] man. Thank you for
the $5. Hugely appreciated. I'm going to
run it back a bit. I want to really
savor this, guys. I want to really savor
some of this. Okay. Implicit in your
doxing, swatting, and harassment. I
thought that's why they deserve to be
doxed. No, it's because they have
engaged in a year and a half post
[__] We could just watch your
content for the last 6 months and see
you running away from your own talking
points.
>> How are How are you running away from
your own talking points right now?
>> These aren't my talking points. These
are the talking points that I'm
>> Okay, so why did esports Batman deserve
to get docked?
>> No, I'm going to answer the other
question that you asked me before you
try to railroad to some other question.
You said, "What is my issue with these
people?" And I've said it and I've
clarified it 50 billion [__] times.
is that for a year and a half, these
people have run a real life long-term
harassment campaign that has
encapsulated multiple channels, multiple
Discords, and multiple mediums like
websites like Kiwi Farms and Discord and
other people's stream chats and other
people's [__] donations and
everything else that that has been
dedicated to the total destruction of my
career and my life. That's been my
issue.
>> Yeah. And they're stochastically
responsible for your swatting and
doxing. Yeah,
>> Connor, I'm not a baby. I don't give a
[__] if some cops show up to my house
with some guns. What I care about is if
people are getting harassed who are
peripheral to me in my life where people
are making threats to them where these
people are not the worst
yesterday about [__] doxing. Swatting
is annoying. I do admit it and I do
consider a kind of attempted murder but
I could deal with that. What I can't
deal with is every single person
peripheral in my life getting mind
[__] Like I'm watching you. You're
mind raked right now. That stuff is a
lot worse to me because I have no
control over that. I can't do anything
to influence that than my [__] rifles
again. Do you think Jtock convinced me
that you engage with like insane sexual
behaviors that puts you at incredible
risk?
>> Your obsession with my [__] has nothing
to do with anything that's happened over
the past 2 years,
>> except for the fact, you [__] [__]
that you were sexing an unstable woman
who is still threatening suicide at this
moment,
>> bro. and who was married to your
political opposition who wants to kill
you.
>> I just want to ask you one fair
question. Who who gave you this idea
that this person is like anything
relevant to any of the past year and a
half of real life harassment towards
other people I know of harassment
anybody follow?
>> He's got nothing to that. It's literally
nothing. So you know that [__] true. You
know that [__] true cuz he's got no
response there. He just tries to walk
him away again at this moment. And who
was and over the past 2 years except for
the fact you [__] [__] that you
were sexing an unstable woman who is
still threatening suicide at this moment
and who was married to your political
opposition who wants to kill you.
>> I just want to ask you one fair
question. Who who gave you this idea
that this person is like anything
relevant to any of the past year and a
half of real life harassment towards
other people I know of harassment
anybody I follow on social media of
interviewing my [__] court case of
reaching out to witnesses
>> he did she mentally unstable woman that
you are sexing
>> her name is first of all I'm not talking
to this person right now okay number one
number two she saved
>> dude so you know he's spoken to her in
like the last day or so right is I'm not
talking to this person right now that
means is like not within like the last
10 minutes that we've I've seen them do
this with Anna, you know. I've already
seen this once with Anna. So you you
know he spoke to her within like the
last day. It's every [__] time, Matt.
It's like every [__] time.
>> Sexual. Is that who she is?
>> Sorry, what
>> is that? Is she Is her name Saba Sexual
online? She's the one in in just Discord
server that reached out to the victim of
my [__]
>> Oh, you [__]
>> Yeah, just just blocked her before
getting on call or some [__] man. For
real.
>> [__] Wait, wait, wait. Hold on.
>> Is she the one? You're saying You're
saying, hold on, hold on. You're saying
I shouldn't care about your sex life.
When you're doing something so reckless
and stupid, it runs the risk of you
getting murdered. I, as your friend,
shouldn't have criticism of you.
>> God, the amount of the amount of pivot
sweep that you've done. None of this has
anything to do with my court case. You
are desperately running for because you
know that you can't.
>> You said it did, you [__] I said that
you are sexually [__] and you're
dangerous to yourself.
>> Okay. All right. That's good. That has
basically nothing to do with any of the
problems that I've been experiencing for
the past 2 years. But unless I guess
>> you don't think that you're in a court
case right now because you're sexually
[__] and a danger to yourself.
>> Who was the I was sexually [__] for
recording videos with Pixie. I shouldn't
have done that six years ago. I guess
Laura and I should
>> I'm sorry. You're almost there. You're
almost at the point. That's actually a
good point.
>> Yeah. Please argue your sexual
retardation and how it resulted in a
court case. Please do.
>> Sexual retardation is is you just not
liking people having casual sex or doing
sexual things because I'm a saint.
>> So crazy. Why won't you say it? Why
won't you say non-consensually sharing
the homemade pornography with someone
you've known for 10 days? Just say that
part. Just say that part.
>> The point that's actually a good point.
>> Yeah. Please articulate your sexual
retardation and how it result
>> that Connor has removed the weight of
his sweeper shackles. He is finally able
to go all out.
>> Thank you for the $4. Thank you. Huge
appreciated guys. Now's a great time to
remind you 771 people here 115 likes on
the stream. Some of those 600 or so
people and please move the cursor thumbs
up and clicking or pressing a thumbs up
on a mobile device. That'd be huge
appreciated. If you want to take your
support one step further, you can do it
directly through streams link in the pin
chat message. You go to buy a membership
channel, gift a membership to channel,
gift a whole bunch of memberships
randomly throughout the chat. Buy a
super chat which will hide your message
and read it on CTS or buy a super
sticker which you image or gift that we
hire to chat. I'll describe it to you.
You can go disc.g/quman twitterman or
write.com/quman.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
>> In a court case
who was the I was sexually [__] for
recording videos with Pixie. I shouldn't
have done that six years ago. I guess
Laura and I
>> I'm sorry. We're almost there. You're
almost at the point. That's actually a
good point.
>> Yeah. Please articulate your sexual
retardation and how it resulted in a
court case. Please do.
>> Sexual retardation is is you just not
liking people having casual sex or doing
sexual things. me because I'm a sane
adult. I don't like that my idiot
millionaire friend who is wildly
intelligent, wildly successful in so
many domains of his life, thought that
it was smart to send homemade
pornography to random people on the
[__] internet.
That's why I'm calling you sex. Thank
you Bar for the membership and thank you
Pat for the five gifted memberships.
Huge appreciate guys. Thank you so much.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you guys.
Huge appreciate for the support. Thank
you.
>> Actually [__] Jtock didn't tell me
that didn't tell thought that it was
smart to send homemade pornography to
and wave with the£5. Huge appreciate.
Thank you so much.
>> Random people on the [__] internet.
That's why I'm calling you sexually
[__] JTO didn't tell me that. We
didn't tell me that.
Doobie didn't tell me that. I thought
that you were sexually [__] myself
and I've called you sexually [__]
for two [__] years.
>> Gotcha. That makes sense.
>> And you're still sexually [__]
>> If a justical fan showed up at my house
and murdered me because they were
>> This is so detached from reality. It's
[__] insane. He's legitimately
pitching the idea that a JT Stalk fan
might show up at his house. The snark I
could name about 10 mentally ill women
Destiny prayed on that I see in chats
daily.
>> Thank you. Weird. Huge appreciate. Thank
you. Um, it's [__] insane. It's so
[__] crazy.
>> Connor, one day you'll discover that
you're not actually a stabled sweeping
Zogo. You're actually very powerful.
Thank you for the $5. Huge appreciated.
And JTO fans don't even leave the house
to date. Okay, they do it all in his
Discord. So, I don't know where the [__]
he's getting the idea that one of them's
going to show up at his house with a
gun. That's certainly not happening.
That is certainly not happening. But
it's just such a deranged, schizophrenic
narrative to pitch. It's just so
bizarre. And this works on on DJs.
They're like, "Yes, J's fans are very
deranged. They they are going to come to
come to Steven's house. We need to we
need to
>> they actually think that they actually
believe this guys. You see endless
Reddit posts of them saying this.
>> Doobie didn't tell me that. I thought
that you were sexually [__] myself
and I've called you sexually [__]
for two [__] years.
>> Gotcha. That makes sense.
>> And you're still sexually [__]
>> If if a justical fan showed up at my
house and murdered me because they were
so upset over the court case, would that
be my fault?
>> Sorry. If who showed up and murdered
you?
>> Jessica fan showed up at my house and
murdered me because they were so upset
about my sexual behavior. Would that be
my fault?
>> Tyler,
>> how about we change it to the griper?
>> Can Can you ask
>> Can you answer that question? You
>> No, no. I I'll answer your question. If
the Groper showed up and murdered you,
Yeah. that be your fault.
>> If one of Jessica's fans showed up at my
house and he murdered me, okay? Would
that be my fault?
>> But but if if the if the husband showed
up and murdered you, would that be your
fault?
>> No. [__] it. He should blame his wife
for that. She didn't say that murder
when she she first reached out to me.
What do you want me to say,
>> dude? Okay. You're You're literally like
>> I'll ask I'm going to ask the main point
is you are sexually [__]
>> She didn't say she was married. She
didn't say not he couldn't have known.
Not he didn't know. Not I looked and I
couldn't tell. I couldn't see that she
was married. Dude, you are a millionaire
niche celebrity. Do a little bit of
thinking about the women you're gonna
send stuff to, engage with. A little bit
of inadvanced thinking. Don't just
instantly reply to that DM. Maybe it
destroys your career.
>> No, that's not the main point, you
[__] [__] The main point is
there's been a 2-year mass harassment
campaign that [__] retards like you.
I guess cuz I'm not going to be
personal. Okay, listen. Whatever
problems or issues that you have going
on right now, the fact that you are
willing to sweep every [__] thing
that these lunatics are doing online
because you don't like the way that I
have [__] casual sex is the most
insanely petty cockwatch I've ever heard
in my entire [__] life. It's crazy to
me. Destiny, I'm not the person being
sued for $15 million for being a sexual
[__] I'm not the [__] person who
is getting [__] sex videos from a
griper and his wife, you psycho.
>> Is that why I'm being sued?
>> No, but that's why you're going to get
murdered, you [__]
>> Is that why is that why I'm being sued?
>> You're being sued for being sexually
[__] 100%.
>> Okay, so just help me draw the line
time. So, no more recording videos or no
more having casual sex at all.
>> Playing like playing [__] [__]
It's so crazy.
>> Age play. Tom and Willie Mack are still
on the plantation. Btw,
>> thank you for the $5. Thank you. This is
just [__] crazy, man.
>> Women
insane.
>> Why are you saying adult women?
SET YOUR [__] PARAMETERS TO 25 TO 40
AND HAVE SEX WITH PEOPLE THAT YOU HAVE A
CONVERSATION with for MORE THAN 30
[__] SECONDS. IT'S SO NORMAL. It's so
normal. As many PEOPLE AS YOU WANT, BUT
STOP BANGING people who are [__]
crazy.
>> Okay. You want to know somebody a lot of
You want to know somebody who had a lot
of conversations with who is pretty
close to my age, who's probably more
responsible court case. I know it's
[__] Lauren de Laguna. But great
advice. Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> I'm sorry. What the [__] does Lauren de
Laguna have?
>> Literally, it's like literally has
nothing. He's just desperately trying to
put in the like uh red meat lines for
for his for his uh heavily Hindu fan
base. It's like, oh, you've heard that
name before, right? That's the name
that's behind all the horrible things
that happened to me.
>> Another [__] that you [__] who's
crazy who's trying to ruin your life. As
a matter of fact, hold on. THAT'S A
GREAT POINT, DESTINY. THERE'S ANOTHER
[__] THAT YOU [__] THAT'S TRYING TO
RUIN YOUR goddamn life.
>> Thank you for bringing her up. I forgot
about Lauren Day Lagona. True.
>> You You know what happened today? Pilot
Pila texted me today. Pilot texted me
today and she said, "Oh man,
>> so we get an aerodite leak here, guys.
We get an aerodite leak here.
>> You for bringing her up. I forgot about
Lauren de Lagona."
>> True.
>> You know what happened today? Pilot Hila
texted me today. Pilot texted me today
and she said, "Oh man, Steven's going
crazy. You know, this kind of reminds me
of uh back what happened with Lauren."
And do you know what I had to say in
response? Which Lauren? Dude, it's just
perfect. It's just perfect. It's so
insane. The bombs dropping. It's crazy.
And they literally, you could just tell
all of all of his friends can see that
this guy is totally [__] losing his
mind. And it's just these sickopant
retards, self-interested [__] losers
like Wick and Stardust cheering it on
while the people that are actually close
to him. Cuz, you know, I do think
Arerodite, you know, does legitimately
care about Destiny. I think she's a
disgusting person, a complete psycho and
uh wants to help him do terrible things
or is willing to at least. Uh but I
don't I think she actually does care
about him and she's clearly messaging in
the background being like this is
[__] crazy. This guy's losing it and
he's literally not listening and these
[__] sick of fans cheer it on. It's
so [__] insane. The whole setup is
just so [__]
>> You know why? because you've had sex
with two or three of them and one of
them's [__] crazy and trying to ruin
your life
>> because you're direction. It's a It's an
easy mistake.
>> Just one Lauren everywhere, you know.
>> North south.
>> Dude, if you could have [__] Chen, you
would have [__] Chen, too.
>> This would have been okay. Excuse me.
Chen's pretty hot. Okay, number one.
Number two, if the if the whole thing is
you hate me having casual sex, then just
say that and then you can cut out all
the [__]
>> I love you and I want you to stop being
[__]
>> Shut the [__] up. Oh my god, it's such a
cringe thing to say. Shut the [__] up.
Okay, stop bringing on just
>> You say you love me after every
conversation. Did you not mean it? You
[__]
>> He says an hair.
>> Weird psychosexual [__] you're on right
now. Okay.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Everybody, dude, we all know the entire
world knows your sexual history, but I'm
the crazy one. As a matter of fact,
let's move off of your sexual history.
Let's go into the doxing history. What
did Esports Batman do to deserve to be?
>> People like you obsess over it. Esports
Batman cheered on as a Discord server,
gave legal advice to a Discord server
that was do that was harassing a [__]
sex trafficking victim, encouraging him
to jo.
That's what he did, Conor.
>> That's No, he didn't.
>> Did he dox you?
>> No.
>> Did he stalk you?
>> I would consider that stalking. Yes.
>> Oh,
>> dude. Okay. Uh, did he swap you?
>> You noticed how Connor doesn't respond
to what I saying yesterday run down to
check.
>> Yeah, because you're [__] [__]
Because people talking [__] about you ON
THE INTERNET IS NOT A GOOD REASON to dox
them, you [__] [__] Hold on. I
just want to hear you say this. I just
want to hear you say this to be clear.
People reaching out to the victim of a
sex trafficking crime in order to harass
her and her family to force her to draw
my case. That's just people talking
[__] Connor,
>> no. Caiba could be the one person where
if you doxed him, I'd be like, "Ah, but
esports Batman isn't Caiba, is he?"
>> Do you think that Caiba exists without a
whole Discord server cheering him the
[__] on?
>> Okay. Yeah. I I I love this. So, so
since I'm
>> everything
>> and since I enjoy I'm just mind raped by
the snarkers now I side with Queman
Jtock and Doobie and since I agree with
them about everything, I should dox CFKA
because he enables the infinite rape
machine based off of your logic.
>> Do you think that
>> he's fair game? He talks to you. He's a
lawyer. He gives you legal feedback. I
should rape him.
>> I should kill him.
>> Sure. Show me Show me Kfka engaging in
the behavior that was anywhere near what
esports Batman does. You know what? No.
No, no. It really It really boils down
to this.
>> Oh my god.
>> It really boils down to this. If you're
going to dox people,
>> have a good reason and evidence it. You
haven't done that. And if you're going
to have sex with people,
>> Connor just like Connor just raping kind
of just laying it down, man. It's
[__] awesome.
>> Stop having sex with crazy people who
are going to ruin your [__] life.
>> I'll just repeat that over and over and
over again. I don't want to litigate
every [__] detail with you because I
don't give a [__] What I'm saying right
now is so true. And here's the other
thing. Here's the other thing. Before
you [__] dip out,
he just held this guy in place the whole
time. Laid it out so great. It's [__]
awesome.
>> [__] psychosexually. You know what?
Dan and Mutton are [__] [__]
because they would never [__] say
this [__] to your [__] face, you
[__] loser.
>> Things in life. No, they would. Except
they do in real life. They don't have to
do a show.
>> They do. Then why don't you listen to
him, you stupid [__] Every single one
of your friends is consistently telling
you that you are so sexually [__]
that you are ruining your life and yet
you are coming to me and saying,
"Connor, you're dick watching. You're
psychosexually obsessing with me." Hold
on. So, if I'm psychosexually obsessed
with you, why are Dan saying the same
thing? Is he psychosexually obsessed
with you? Is Mutton? Is Kyla? Is
>> Lauren with me?
>> How many friends do you have left? By
the way, AT WHAT POINT DO YOU GO, "OH
[__] it's me. I got as many wives as
you have left, Connor.
>> So, he's he like just jumping on his
[__] divorce when it's like that
really doesn't say that much about
Connor, you know? He like Con's about to
say, he was married for like 15 years
and seemingly they had a good
relationship for most of that time.
>> What the [__] bro? You want to talk
about
>> married for 15 YEARS AND I WAS LOYAL to
one WOMAN FOR 15 YEARS. BUT HOLD ON,
LET'S POINT OUT HOW [__] STUPID WHAT
YOU JUST SAID WAS. HOW MANY WIVES DO YOU
HAVE LEFT, CONOR? I HAD ONE. AND I WAS
married to her for 15 years. And I was
loyal to her for 15 years. You [__]
idiot.
>> Oh my god. Keep going. Are you good?
>> No, I'm good. Yeah, you're a [__]
idiot. You think one 15-year
relationship compares to your entire
life of social sexual dysfunction?
>> It's just amazing. It's just peak. It's
just peak. It's just peak. It's just
facts. Just absolutely destroyed. That's
so [__] I don't even know why you
would say it.
>> Connor, weren't we standing outside your
house when you were asking me? I should
live a sexual life like you now. I
should go and have all this [__] fun
NOW THAT I'M [__]
>> YEAH. AND YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED? I GOT
TINDER. I DID ONE HOOKUP. I was like,
"This is gay and cringe. I'm going to go
find a serious girlfriend." And then I
got a serious girlfriend because I'm
almost 30. For you. I guess you're just
not very
personal. Don't take it out on me.
Grow up. You're 40.
>> Grow up, Conor. You are
>> It's just crazy. What can you even say,
man? It's It's just facts. It's all just
facts. He's a young 37. And the thing
is, he tries to say this like he's
leaking something about Connor and
Connor's been like totally open about
like all his divorce stuff, you know?
He's l he's literally gone out there,
said it all, gone on streams to talk
about it more. And Destiny thinks he's
like like these are like awesome [__]
leaks, you know, that he's getting in
there. Sick jabs. There's a bit later on
in the night from this where Destiny's
on um on Radiant Souls stream and he's
going like Con should see what what
Queen and J and all these guys were
saying about his divorce the other week.
He's seen. He knows. He He gets it. He
He takes his licks and moves on and
doesn't spend a year and a half doxing
and crashing out over it. This why
people respect him more than you.
>> Is Lauren with me?
>> One of many reason [__] say this [__]
to your [__] face, you [__] loser.
>> Things in life. No, they would. Except
they do in real life. They don't have to
do a show.
>> They do. Then why don't you listen to
him, you stupid [__] Every single one
of your friends is consistently telling
you that you are so sexually [__]
that you are ruining your life, and yet
you are coming to me and saying,
"Connor, you're dick watching. You're
psychosexually obsessing with me." Hold
on. So if I'm psychosexually obsessed
with you, why are Dan saying the same
thing? Is he psychosexually obsessed
with you? Is mutton is Kyla? Is Lauren
with me?
>> How many friends do you have left? By
the way, AT WHAT POINT DO YOU GO, "OH
[__] it's me."
>> As many wives as you have left, Connor.
What the [__] bro? Do you want to TALK
ABOUT
>> MARRIED FOR 15 YEARS? AND I WAS LOYAL to
one WOMAN FOR 15 YEARS. BUT HOLD ON.
LET'S POINT OUT HOW [__] STUPID WHAT
YOU JUST SAID WAS. HOW MANY WIVES DO YOU
HAVE LEFT? CONOR HAD ONE. AND I was
married to her for 15 years. And I was
loyal to her for 15 years. You [__]
idiot.
>> Oh my god. Keep going. Are you good?
>> No, I'm good. Yeah, you're a [__]
idiot. You think one 15-year
relationship compares to your entire
life of social sexual dysfunction?
That's so [__] I don't even know
why you would say it.
>> Connor, weren't we standing outside your
house when you were asking me, "I should
live a sexual life like you now. I
should go and have all this [__] fun
NOW THAT I'M [__]
>> YEAH. AND YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED? I GOT
TINDER. I DID ONE HOOKUP. I was like,
"This is gay and cringe. I'm gonna go
find a serious girlfriend." And then I
got a serious girlfriend because I'm
almost 40.
>> I guess you're just not very gonna say
that's a personal problem. Don't take it
out on me.
>> Grow up. You're 40.
>> Grow up, Connor. You are on the internet
talking about sex.
>> You are age playing with a griper's
wife.
You are age playing with a griper's
wife. And I have
>> You are age playing with a griper.
>> New rule. Connor cannot have a debate
unless he has exclusive one-on-one
interviews with Quean and JSTLK.
In that order. Thanks for your attention
to this matter.
>> Thank you for the $4. Thank you. Oh, $5.
Fairly appreciate. Thank you. Says new
Connor Discord rules. We're going to let
everybody fight until midnight EST.
After that, we we will enforce two new
rules. Three snarks and you're out.
Excessively [__] talking a creator
outside of the context of a current
event in attempt to get a hate brigade
going will be worn twice and then
banned. Two, the nword with an a in a
non-porative context will be permitted
for all users. Any porative use of the
er in porative context will result in a
ban or warning without a ban of anyone
context.
Oh my god.
>> Grow up.
>> Respectfully, you have no idea what
you're talking about. Okay.
>> No, I do.
>> I got the logs
>> from him and from her
on the internet talking about sex.
>> You are age playing with a
>> Grow up. You're 40.
>> Grow up, Connor. You are on the internet
talking about sex. You are age playing
with a griper's wife.
You are age playing with a griper's
wife. And
>> you are age playing with a griper
wife.
>> Grow up.
>> Respectfully, you have no idea what
you're talking about. Okay.
>> No, I do.
>> I got the logs from him and from her.
>> That's great. Okay. I don't The thing is
I don't want to out their business on
the internet. Okay, but you don't know
what you're talking about. I promise
you. Okay,
>> guys. Guys, it's another self-defense of
sexing. You don't understand. He has to.
You don't. Connor, if only you knew the
full story here, you would realize that
he has to age play with the grier's wife
because it it prevents a greater harm.
there. If you approach this from a
utilitarian perspective, he actually has
to age play with the groper's wife in a
self-defensive manner because it will
prevent a greater harm to himself. So,
Connor, how about you just shut the [__]
up for a minute and just wait for the
manifesto.
>> I have screenshots. I know what I'm
talking about. SO, HOW ABOUT YOU JUST
GO, "DAMN, CONNOR, you're right. I
shouldn't be accepting sexual videos
from a griper and his wife who wants to
murder me. I need to CHILL THE [__] OUT.
>> YOU said you have screenshots. Who sent
you the screenshots?
>> Are we
>> I'm not sending you the screenshots of
the [__] graer who wants to murder.
>> I have to pretend she's my best.
>> But trust me, I have them. And the
reason why he can't deny it is because
he knows it's [__] true.
>> It's because you have a fraction of
this.
>> Conor. Yeah. Conor, are you really doing
this right now? right before the
midterms. Connor, don't you know we need
Destiny's to defeat Trump?
>> Story that is absolutely not worth
what could you possibly tell me that is
going to tell that's going to be like,
"Oh [__] Destiny was right. He should
have sexed the groper and his wife.
>> OH MY GOD, THIS is brilliant. What
information or context could you
possibly share with me that would change
my opinion on this?" I am not going to
out parts of any conversation like this
that I have with another person or
people. You're [__] insane to even
ask me to do that.
>> You're correct.
>> No, I'm not. I see my friend who's a
[__] idiot [__] up and I've tried
to be nice about it and that's not
working. So, I'm going to be [__]
mean about it. You're sexually [__]
[__] You don't know how to manage
your relationships. Anytime anybody
[__] challenges you on anything, even
if they love you, you run away because
you're afraid of growing up. You are not
13 anymore. You are 40. Grow up.
>> It's all there. Every piece is in place.
The Infinity Stones have merged.
>> He's He's dodging his ex-wife wife's
lies like he's Neo in the Matrix. He's
going into bullet time. He can see
through it. He can see through it all,
guys. All of it's falling into place.
Lighting me. all of it falling. Sherlock
mind pass. All of it's falling into
place. Finally, he understands Connor
has actually uh been mind controlled by
YouTube content and totally hasn't come
to an independent conclusion based on
his extensive personal experience with
Destiny and seeing his life play out
over numerous years. Uh and actually
actually Connor's mind controlled and is
not giving him genuine advice and trying
to reach through to him in the midst of
a manic episode right now. No, no, he's
been he's totally mind controlled. He's
mind control. He's doing this to to own
him online. He sees through it, guys.
God. God. God. You did it again. Steven,
I can't wait for the manifesto. Yeah,
sure. I'll give you one more. You know,
Lauren wanted to get back with you.
Really?
>> Yes. She loves you. She wants the best
for you. She thinks that underneath all
the sludge and [__] of your [__]
up little life, there is something
redeeming about you. And I agree with
her, BUT YOU ARE SUCH A [__] [__]
>> that it is impossible.
>> Really?
>> Yes, she loves you. Anytime anybody
[__] challenges you on anything, even
if they love you, you run away because
you're afraid of growing up. You are not
13 anymore. You are 40. Grow up.
>> It's all there. Every piece is in place.
The Infinity Stones have merged.
>> Yeah, sure. I'll give YOU ONE MORE. YOU
know Lauren wanted to get back with you.
Really?
>> Yes. She loves you. She
>> crazy. It just cuts so [__] deep,
dude. You can just tell. You can just
tell. It's [__] insane.
>> Oh my god.
>> It's all there. Every piece is in place.
The Infinity Stones have merged.
>> Yeah, sure. I'll give you one more. You
know Lauren wanted to get back with you.
>> Really?
>> Yes. She loves you. She wants the best
for you. She thinks that underneath all
the sludge and [__] of your [__]
up little life, there is something
redeeming about you. And I agree with
her. BUT YOU ARE SUCH A [__] [__]
that it is impossible to be your friend.
It's impossible to be your partner. It
is impossible to tell you that YOU'RE
WRONG. IT'S IMPOSSIBLE for you to take a
[__] L. The insane just [__] combo
here. literally just stun locked or
Connor just like says the realest [__]
to this guy just like, "Bro, you got to
[__] up so bad for your friends to be
saying this [__] to you, man. You got to
[__] up so [__] bad." And it's just
crazy. He's just totally exposed. He's
just totally exposed. It's [__]
crazy.
>> Every piece is in place. The Infinity
Stones have merged. Yeah, sure. I'll
give you
>> see. It's hilarious to even try and say
that, man. You're literally Keep a note
of that.
>> One more. You know, Lauren wanted to get
back with you.
>> Clearly paying no attention.
>> Yes. She loves you. She wants the best
for you. She thinks that underneath all
the sludge and [__] of your [__]
up little life, there is something
redeeming about you. And I agree with
her. BUT YOU ARE SUCH A [__] [__]
that it is impossible to be your friend.
It's impossible to be your partner. It
is impossible to tell you that you're
wrong. IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR YOU TO take a
[__] L. So take a [__] L and take
a goddamn lap.
>> Connor, if you want a [__] L, me and
Lauren have been dating for like 3
months and we both agreed not to tell
you because you asked her.
>> So I'm going to pause it right there
because he just lied. He just lied,
guys. He's not dating Lauren. He's not
dating Lauren. He just lied.
He just lied that he's still dating
Lauren to try and get one over on Connor
in this conversation. Dude, it's [__]
crazy. He literally immediately after
this, he goes into DGG chat and admits.
He says, "Guys, I'm sorry. I
misrepresented. me and Lauren broke up
two weeks ago. She's been so [__] over
by every guy in her life. No joke.
That's what he goes to DG and says
immediately after, you know, he's
trembling, freaking the [__] out because
he obviously actually does kind of care
about Lauren a little bit deep down and
he just literally he throws it away in
this moment to try and get the win for
his ego. Dude,
it's like it's Shakespearean. It's
Shakespearean, guys. It's Shakespearean.
It really is. Thank you for the five
gifted Corave Valley. Huge appreciate
for the five gifted Isu. Hugely
appreciated. Thank you so much. Oh my
god. It's It's just Dude, it's [__]
crazy. He straight just lies about his
relationship with her. So, it kind of
does actually clarify, but because
Destiny uh is like a disgusting rodent
and has a cult full of sick events, uh
they actually don't, no one like
realizes, none of the audience obviously
is realizing in the moment that Connor
actually points out that this is a lie
because Destiny has managed to create
the spectacle, which is why I paused it
by the way to undercut it um to to
overwrite it
because that's all he can do. But all he
can do is deflect and create spectacle
to try and make the other person look
bad. He's got nothing. So I just wanted
to pause it immediately, undercut that
and then we can watch it through
understanding that Connor does actually
correct him immediately. So let's see.
And I agree with her. BUT YOU ARE SUCH A
[__] [__] THAT IT is impossible to
be your friend. It's impossible to be
your partner. It is impossible to tell
you that you're wrong. It's impossible.
So take a [__] L and take a goddamn
lap.
>> Connor, if you want a [__] L, me and
Lauren have been dating for like 3
months and we both agreed not to tell
you because you asked her out while we
were in the middle of dating. You have
NO [__] IDEA WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT WITH LITERALLY ANYTHING YOU'RE
SAYING.
>> YES, I DO BECAUSE I DURING THE TWO WEEKS
AND YOU WERE TOO MUCH OF a
>> So Connor says there I talked during the
last two weeks.
>> Cigars red heart emoji.
>> Thank you for the membership, Herby.
Thank you.
and and the five gifted Harvey. Huge
appreciated.
So Connor says that he spoke to her in
the last two weeks and obviously we know
Destiny goes to DG chat and admits they
broke up about two weeks ago. So
obviously Connor knows obviously Connor
knows what's actually going on here as
much as Destiny is pretending otherwise.
Me and Lauren have been dating for like
3 months and we both agreed not to tell
you because you asked her out while we
were in the middle of dating. You have
NO [__] IDEA WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT WITH LITERALLY ANYTHING YOU'RE
SAYING.
>> YES, I DO BECAUSE I DURING THE WEEKS AND
YOU WERE TOO MUCH OF A [__] TO
COMMIT.
>> SO, and that that's what's going on
here. Lauren wanted commitment. Lauren
wanted a real relationship and he w he
could not do it.
>> You were TOO MUCH OF A [__] HUSBAND
TO COMMIT. OH. OH, NO. THIS HOT INTERNET
POLITICS AUTIST WHO I DESTROYED MY LIFE
FOR IN 2022. OH, SHE LOVES ME. I NEED TO
GO SEX BPD [__] You're a [__]
idiot. You're an idiot.
>> You You literally had Lauren back and
you ditched her for BPD girls because
you're sexually [__] You are
[__]
>> Conor, you don't know anything about my
life. You don't know anything about me
personally.
>> YES, I DO ANYTHING ABOUT THE OTHER
LIVES.
>> DO DO YOU WANT ME TO GET THE SCREENSHOTS
THAT I GOT FROM Lauren Southern?
>> Are self-destructing right now? Because
I I think we should take one week off.
But that's my suggestion. I
>> It's just crazy. He's He literally just
lied to try and get out of this about
Lauren and he's trying to spin it back
around at Connor.
>> Why you had faith in Connor? Truly the
last noble conservative, the last real
friend Destiny had. He still has a soul.
>> Thank you for the five Australian
dollars. Thank you. You'd appreciate
>> you.
You should take a whole year off. Do you
know here? Here here's another thing.
Here's another thing.
>> All right, he's gone. I'll go ahead and
share it with the people who are
watching.
>> He did mushrooms that said that he was
alone inside his room and he ignored
that. But exactly what the [__] is
happening is he can't take criticism. He
can't let people love him. He can't let
anybody get [__] close. And he would
rather cycle through a [__] roster of
BPD e [__] and slowly destroy his
[__] life rather than get his [__]
together and grow the [__] up. And I'm
sick of it. I played nice with it. I'm
not playing nice with it anymore. I'm
>> Please, please, please. But do you think
now is the time to litigate?
>> So Destiny has ran. He's left the
conversation. He just left
>> exife and he literally under
>> he left and he went straight into DG
chat and he says this. Sorry. [__] me. I
misrepresented. We broke up like once
two months ago. I hate that I'm even
outing anything of her personal life.
Holy [__] Lauren's been so unbelievably
[__] by men her entire life.
And then Lauren and me mutually agreed
to split two months ago because our
lifestyles were way way way too
different. She's a bit more in her. I
want to do serious settle down media
kind of stuff. I'm still very much in
the I'm fighting for my life every day
and I love the battle. Let's go with my
brothers among other things. 40-year-old
man by the way.
>> It is not. Yes, it is. You're watching a
man. Absolutely.
>> And he's trying.
>> Yeah. Literally used her as a shield.
It's so not even as a shield. He used
her as a [__] sword. Let's be real.
He was trying to hurt Connor PD [__]
and slowly destroy his [__] life
rather than get his [__] together and
grow the [__] up. And I'm sick of it. I
played nice with it. I'm not playing
nice with it anymore. I'm done.
>> I understand. Please, please, please.
But do you think now is the time to
litigate his sex life when he's
literally under attack? It is not.
You're watching a man and he's trying.
Like, this is what I mean. Anyone doing
this [__] just outs themselves are so
self-interested and they do not give a
[__] about this guy. Don't get me wrong,
I don't give a [__] about this guy
either. And honestly, if he doesn't
change, that's way better for me. Um,
but there is no way you can pretend to
care about this guy and be saying the
[__] Wick's saying here. You You have to
just recognize, okay, Connor is clearly
doing this because he gives a [__] You
know, there is no other read here. It's
[__] absurd. sit here with you want
to sit here with a straight [__] face
and you want to tell me that he should
be sexing a [__] groper and his wife
while he's ongoing litigation for sexing
for for leaking [__] homemade
pornography.
>> That's the appropriate time to [__] with
BPD e girls that you're you're really
angry and I get it and and I'm not
saying you don't have any reason not to
be ang to be angry, right? But like this
is not the time. This is not the place.
>> Yes, it is.
It's exactly the time and the place.
>> It's exactly. You know why? Because it's
been years.
>> I'm using my snarks on wick.
>> I'm using my three allotted counterpoint
snarks on wick. Thank you for the $10.
Huge appreciate. Thank you.
>> It's been years. No one will stand up to
this [__] and tell him to his
face that he's being a [__] [__]
And you know what? I don't give a [__]
He knows that I'm [__] right. He's
sexually [__] He destroys career
opportunities for his own [__]
nihilist hedonism. He could improve his
relationships, but he [__] won't. He
has opportunities for deeper
relationships, and he runs away from
them. [__] that. This is the exact time
to [__] litigate it. And by the way,
here's another [__] detail. Hanging
out with a [__] pedophile. WHY IS HIS
NUMBER ONE defender a [__] pedophile?
>> His kid is getting doxed and you're the
one blaming him for hedonism. That is
ridiculous.
>> You're a pedophile. Oh, that's
>> Why would I talk to you,
>> dude? You
>> Jesus,
>> dude. Oh my god.
>> Was good the entire time.
>> No, just zero respect for food shops
whatsoever. It's just It's just awesome.
It's just pig.